thanks for the intro max that was so
much fun i'm so excited to get to
present here in oklahoma
we're going to dig into leveling up your
devops with github actions and
kubernetes
now here's the part where i tell you i'm
definitely going to post the code on my
site tonight
you're going to go look on my site
tonight tomorrow
next week next month it is online right
now you can grab a link to this
by going to robrich.org wait a minute
this code is empty yes this is an empty
repository and we are going to build up
the code in this repository
right now let's head over to robrich.org
here's level up your devops with github
actions and kubernetes and you can click
into the code right here if it's easier
for you to get to robrich.org
click on presentations and that'll get
you straight to the repo
while we're here on robrich.org thanks
for the intro max here are some of the
things that i've done recently
i'm a cyril developer advocate a
microsoft mvp
a friend of redgate and azgive campus
really cool azgive camp brings volunteer
developers
together with charities to build free
software we start friday after work
sunday afternoon we deliver that
completed software to the charities
sleep is optional caffeine provided if
you're in phoenix come join us for the
next a-z gift camp or if you'd like a
gift camp here in oklahoma or wherever
you're connecting from
hit me up on email or twitter and let's
get a gift camp in your neighborhood too
some of the other things that i've done
i do a lot of training with
docker and with kubernetes and
my claim to fame i replied to a.net
rocks podcast episode they read my
comment on the air
and they sent me a mug so
there's my coveted.net rocksmug so let's
dig in
and build some code here now our goal is
to build a devops pipeline
that will deploy a website into
kubernetes
so we need to start with a website i
have here a completely empty folder
here's my folder and uh
it's completely empty so let's fire it
up and
let's build a website
now if we say dot net new then we can
get a whole bunch of options for
scaffolding out a website
now we could build a react site or an
mvc site a blazer site
in this case let's build an mvc site so
dot net new
i'm going to give it a name of level up
dev ops if i didn't give it this name it
would use my current folder name
i'm also going to say output into the
current folder so it won't create a
nested folder
now this will scaffold out a website oop
net new ah i didn't say mvc
nbc dash dash name level up devops dash
dash output
now the cool part starting in net core 3
it now
restores the nuget packages too so let's
pop open this folder
inside of vs code and we can see that
this is just a regular website we could
have created this in visual studio
or in any other environment we have
controllers
we have views so here's the view
instead of saying welcome let's say
welcome to
200 okay
very nice okay now we want to get this
into a git repository
our first stop in getting it to a git
repository
is to create a new oh do we want to
create
the missing files yes now when i say yes
it will create this new dot vs code
folder that will allow me to
do debugging inside of vs code now i
won't use
this in this demo but that's really
helpful
okay so our first stop in creating a git
repository is a dot
git ignore file now these are all of the
things
that we don't want to put into our
repository
bin obj star.user the
vs folder star.suo now we can list
all of the built content here all of the
libraries that we're
restoring so if we're in a node project
we'll probably also want to ignore the
node
modules folder if we're in a legacy.net
project
we might also ignore the packages folder
okay so we've got
this list of things that we
don't want to commit to our repository
perfect now our next step
is to start up building out our
container
now i'm going to start by creating a new
file and this will be a
docker ignore now this docker ignore
file
is all of the files that we don't want
to copy into our container
well it actually uses an identical
structure to the dot git ignore file
so let's just copy the get ignore
content here into the docker ignore
and now it won't copy in all of our
built or development resources
now there's a few more things here in
a.net project we have app settings
dot development dot json that we
definitely don't want in our production
container
and we also have here in properties this
launch settings
dot json now this launch
settings.json is all of the details that
we would need to launch this inside
visual studio
and to debug it on the command line we
definitely don't want that in a
production container
okay we've got a docker ignore file now
this docker ignore specifies everything
that will never
end up in our container now what if i
actually
do want to put this app settings
development.json even if i specifically
copy that file into place because i've
chosen to ignore it here it won't go in
okay next step is to create a docker
file
now this is specifically dockerfile
not dockerfile.txt if you accidentally
named it dockerfile.txt come in here and
rename it pull the
txt off and make sure it's just
dockerfile
yeah windows is going to get a little
grumpy because it has no extension
but yeah it's a dockerfile now this
file is the configuration as code that
we need to be able to build up our
container
and there's a couple of verbs that we
use in this
from copy
run cmd and we'll get to see each of
those commands in action today
let's start with from from we will then
specify
the base image that we want to build on
top of we want to
stand on the shoulders of giants so
let's head out to docker hub
and take a look at the content well i'm
going to
search here for dot net and pick the.net
repo
here we are on the.net repo now this
links to other repos
the sample repo is great if you want to
take a look at lots of different
editions of docker files that do
interesting things
there's the runtime dependencies which
is the base unit for all of the things
dotnet runtime this is great for console
apps
asp.net core runtime that builds on top
of the runtime and adds in the web
hosting details
and then the net sdk that stands on top
of the asp.net core runtime
that adds all of our build tools now we
want to build inside of the container
so let's start here i'm going to pop
this open in docker hub
and let's take a look at the content
that we have now we're using
net5 so here's our base image let's copy
this
scrolling down a bit i can see the
various
docker files that build up the various
editions now if we just use the 5.0 tag
as we saw above it would be built on top
of debian
but i see that there's an alpine version
here too and alpine is a really really
lightweight linux image and so if i
build my image on top of alpine that
will make my image a lot smaller
let's do that so let's use the 5.0 dash
alpine tag okay back here in vs code
let's paste this into place
mcr.microsoft.com we'll use the alpine
variant
and now we need to copy in all of our
content
so i'm going to copy all of the content
from this folder where i run
docker build to the current folder
inside of my image now where is that
folder
workthrough src let's call it that
now there's nothing magic about src i
could call it
app i could put it inside var libs
somewhere
it will actually create that directory
if it doesn't exist and cd into that
directory
okay so we just copied all of our
content from this folder
into this folder into this spot in our
image
now we need to run some build commands
now we'll do a dotnet restore
restore that will restore all of our
nuget packages we'll do a
net build we'll build in release mode
we'll do a net test now we'll also say
release mode here
so that it won't rebuild in development
and then rebuild back again and release
and then we're going to do a net publish
now this publish
is much like if we right clicked and
said publish inside visual studio
now the difference is we're doing this
inside of a build script so it will do
it identically every time but here's the
command line that we need to run to do
that
dot net restore to get our
libraries.netbuild.nettest.net publish
and we'll do all those in released mode
now we do need to run them as docker
commands
so let's run this one and
run this one and run
this one and run this one each one of
these will build up new layers
inside of our docker image with that
content specific to that command
okay now we need to switch over to
running our site we output this content
into the disk directory
so let's change our workdir to slash
dist
and cmd is the command that will start
up
our project and so we're going to say
net
level up dev ops dot blo
perfect now we do need to set some
environment variables and some content
just for the sake of expediency i'll
just copy and paste those into place
we're setting our environment variable
to production
we're setting net to listen on
port 80 and we're exposing port 80 for
inbound traffic
now we've got a docker file that works
perfectly we could push this into
production right now
but there are some inefficiencies that
we could
that we could correct here right now we
have the build tools in our container we
also have our source code in the
container
now we could do something like this we
could say
uh let's not delete the disk folder run
rm minus rf src and that would
definitely remove our source code
but each of these commands creates a
layer
so this command actually would create a
new layer
with tombstones for each of those files
we're not making our image smaller
we're just making that those files not
exist from here down
but they still exist up here let's not
do that
instead let's head back over to docker
hub and as we're looking here at docker
hub
let's flip over to the asp.net
repository
now in this asp.net repository we only
have the asp.net run time
and scrolling down a bit we can take a
look at
all of the docker files and tags that we
have available oh there's an alpine
variant with 5.0 dash alpine
let's use that so i'm going to split
this in half
let's say from and we'll add this new
asp.net
alpine right there
and now this one will be our runtime
container and this one will be
our build server container now i miss
using that term it's not a server
but it kind of functions in that way and
this will be our production
runtime server container
okay so we've got our production runtime
we've got our build server and they are
now
separate now we do need to copy this
disk folder into place
so let's say this is the app folder and
here we'll say copy
we need to copy the dist folder into the
current folder
now we don't want to copy from our host
machine that's what this command would
be right now we want to say
from equals build and where is the build
command well let's name this one as
build we've named this stage as build so
now it'll copy
not from our host machine but from this
dist folder in this build stage
perfect we've created a multi-stage
build
one stage that will do all of our
building run our tests publish our
content
and a second stage that doesn't include
our build tools
that doesn't include our source code it
only includes those built
assets that we want to run now there's
one more improvement that we can
make right now it's going to restore the
new get packages
after it copies in the files so if i
change a javascript file or a css
file it will re-restore my nuget
packages
really i want to do this this way
now that's interesting but i still need
to know what i want to restore so let's
copy in
the level of devops.cs proj into the
current folder
there's my manifest that tells me what
things i need to restore
i'll copy in my manifest then i'll
restore my nuget packages
then i will copy and everything else now
we're using the power of docker
caching so it when
our manifest changes it will invalidate
this layer and we'll re-restore our
nuget packages
if we're only changing source code we
won't invalidate this layer we'll use
the cached copy and only start here
which is perfect now as i'm developing i
can
reiterate a lot faster now we are going
to set this
image aside as we publish this image so
having those extra layers will actually
really help me at build time
but really won't impact production time
at all
now we have a docker file that is great
we have a build server that will do all
the build test and publish content
and we have a runtime server whose sole
purpose in life is to start our website
now let's commit this up to github i'll
come in here to my
git tab in vs code and i will stage all
of these files
we can take a look at them and see have
i committed any secrets have i committed
any
files that i don't want to change i can
start to diff each one
and unfortunately it was empty so
we'll leave that be and now i can
oh we do need to add one more file
though let's go grab a kubernetes yaml
file
now i'm just going to grab the one from
the last time that i did this
here's that kubernetes yaml file from
last time
last time and we can see that this will
create a deployment
and a service now there is quite a bit
of redundancy here
we do need to change last time to level
up
devops and now we've got it pretty well
ready to go
now this will create a deployment only
one copy of the server right now but we
could definitely increase this
it it references some variables acr url
the image label the aks url here in the
ingress controller for dns
we'll be able to swap those secrets into
place in our build pipeline
to keep these secrets out of source
control
now that we've got our kubernetes yaml
file in place let's come back in
and stage that as well and now
we will commit this content level
up level up dev
ops let's commit this
and now that we've got it committed
it status everything's ready to go git
push
origin main
okay now that we've got our content
pushed up to github we can flip back
over to github and we see that we've got
code now in our repository
now this repository was empty well
almost
i did come in here in the settings and i
did create some secrets
here's my secrets and i went new
repository
secret and i gave it a name and a value
and i added that secret
and we can see these secrets that i've
got here my acr password my acr url
acr username aks url and cubeconfig
we'll use these during our build to be
able to do some really cool things
so let's fire up the build i'll come
here into github actions
and now i can pick from various
templates
deploy a node app to azure web apps
openshift ibm terraform there's some
really great workflows here and i can
pop open this and see a whole bunch more
now in this case it guessed that our
template of choice was a jekyll site
it's not so let's look for docker
oh there's a bunch of things with docker
here let's go find
the docker image right here perfect
let's set up this workflow now we could
definitely start with a blank
file as well but uh docker kubernetes
having this one already scaffold out
give us gives us some
help so this is a docker build and push
kubernetes apply
now what branches do we want to do this
on well right now let's only do it on
the main branch
we won't do it for pull requests we
don't want our pull request to
automatically go
into production so first stop it will
check out all of our code that's perfect
next we want to
docker build and push
cube ctl apply
so i'm going to do a multi-stage task
here
there we go i know that the file is
docker file so
that's perfect i'm going to put the dot
at the end
and instead of my image name let's call
this
level up devops and now i want to use my
url
my secrets to be able to form the url of
my registry
so let's head over to the docs for
github
and we can see here on encrypted secrets
i go create a setting
and then once i've got that setting in
place i can use it here with this
secrets dot and then that name with the
two curly braces on either side
let's do that so i've got my registry
name as
secrets.acr url
and now i've tagged that with my url
let's also tag this with our
github.sha that's our build
version our github hash
and so now i have a unique build per
source code
it also allows me because here in the
kubernetes i
added that image label it allows me to
get straight from the running resource
back to the source code that created it
perfect so i've tagged it next i want to
do this
docker push and let's push
this exact tag up to that
docker now before we're able to push
this into our registry we do need to
log into our docker registry
now each of these tasks is able to do a
specific
thing so let's search through the
marketplace and find a task
that allows us to log in to
a docker registry so docker login
docker login that one looks good
now i could choose this one um let's
actually go back
and choose the azure one
uh i'm not seeing it docker login
to acr nope i'm going to choose the
docker one
perfect okay so here i can dig into the
full marketplace listing that will give
me a link to the
github repository that has this task and
it also gives me the yaml snippet that i
need to be able to log
in okay let me go grab that yaml snippet
and paste it here i will need to indent
this correctly
and there we go docker login
now to do the docker login i do need to
set my registry
url good thing we have a secret for that
secrets.acr url
i do need to set my username so let's do
secrets.acr username
and i do need to set my password
yes it can't be null let me set it there
we go
secrets dot acr password
and do i want to log out well yeah let
me log out
now this doesn't log out at the end of
this task but rather at the end of all
of the steps now if i was running on
shared hosting this would be more
important
but because i'm running in a specific vm
on
github actions that is destroyed shortly
after this it's probably less important
but it's still good code hygiene
okay now i've logged into docker and i'm
able to do the things
okay now that my image is up on docker
let's do a cube
ctl apply dash fk8s.yaml
now before we're able to push this into
our kubernetes repository our kubernetes
cluster
we'll need to log into kubernetes let's
come back here into
the marketplace and look for kubernetes
kubernetes set context
okay so uh this one
let's take a look at uh kds that context
yep we can grab the
github url that created this take a look
at the source code that builds that
action
let's grab the yaml and paste that into
place right here
so i've got a couple of ways that i can
get in
um
okay said context
by default i can specify this as cube
config
i can also specify other details like
the context
url token all of those are interesting
but i really like the cube config now we
do have a secret here
for secrets dot
cube config that will get us in and we
can use that to do
our login perfect
so now that we're logged into kubernetes
when we do a cube ctl apply
everything will work great well
kind of here in our kubernetes yaml file
we do have these
content that we need to replace the
image label the acr
url the aks url down here to be able to
get that
the cluster so back here in github
github actions let's do a set command
that will
replace all of those pieces with their
secrets
for the sake of typing we're going to
replace this in our kubernetes yaml file
now we're going to do a sed we won't
back up the file first and we'll replace
acr url with our secret
aks url with our secret and image label
with our github sha
now we specifically did this after we
built and pushed our docker
image in case for example here in our
docker ignore
file we forgot to add the k8s.yaml file
into our ignore
settings now because we forgot that
back here in github actions if we had
said this content into place before we
built and push
then those secrets would end up in our
image let's not do that
let's build and push our image and then
replace these secrets and apply them to
our kubernetes acml file
perfect so we've got this process we'll
check out our code
we'll log into docker so that we're able
to push our thing into our registry
we'll log into kubernetes so that we can
start our content
and then we'll do these four steps build
the
image running all of the steps inside of
our docker file
we'll push that image if that build was
successful we'll replace our secrets and
start that
on kubernetes so now let's come in here
and we will start commit
add build file now the cool part about
this process is that it just becomes one
of the files
in our repository so let's come back in
here
and we will say git pull
and now we've got that new file if i
wanted to i could come back in here and
i could edit it just like any other file
here in our repository
and let's actually do that in a minute
but right now i want to focus on what
it's doing now that this file exists
we have a new build here now it started
a build we can see that with this yellow
dot
and so let's go into the details of this
build
now it's going to do each of those tasks
it will log into docker
it will log into kubernetes and then it
does all of the steps inside of our
docker file so it's going to build it
looks like that build succeeded
then it's going to run all of our tests
all of our tests passed because we
didn't have any
it's going to do a docker publish and
then flip over into that new production
runtime
image and publish all of that content
finally it's now back in our github
actions file where it's pushing that
content into our registry
and ultimately starting it on our
kubernetes cluster
now we saw at the beginning of this talk
how we didn't have anything
inside of kubernetes cube ctl get
all and we see that now we do have that
content running in kubernetes
here's our level up devops um service
it was started 17 seconds ago our pod is
running
16 seconds ago and if we also grab
our ingress we can see that our content
is ready to go now we'll take a while
for
this host to propagate so
let's actually proxy into this pod
instead so we can forward to a
particular pod
we could also forward to a deployment so
it'll randomly pick a pod
let's forward to the service so that we
can validate that
from the service down also works
okay here in our thing we will say
cube ctl port forward
service slash level up dev ops
and we'll go from port 80 on our local
machine to port 80 inside the container
but maybe if something else is running
on port 80 on my local machine i'll
forward port 8080 on my local machine
okay so now i've got that proxy ready to
go let's come here to
localhost 8080
and we can see our website running
inside of kubernetes
welcome to 200 okay
so now we built this build and we're
able to get that content
into production now let's add
a readme file it would be nice to have a
little bit more
content here in our repository we'll
come back here
into our source code we'll create a new
file
readme.md and let's grab some content
that we want to set
inside this readme file here's some
content that just tells a little bit
about our project
wouldn't it be nice if we could also
have a status badge
telling us about the build well let's
come back here here into github actions
we can see our various builds in this
case we have one
and i'm going to go dive into this
particular build
and let's come in here to the three dots
and create a status badge
here is the markdown that we'll need to
put in our readme file to get that
content
let's put it right there
now the other thing that would be really
handy here is if we
had a build for say pull requests so i'm
going to create a new file
docker pr.yaml
now we could definitely go into the
github
actions experience and use the
marketplace and designers there
but i know that i've pretty much got
this file ready to go
so let's set this in place now it's a
docker
build for prs now i want to specifically
do this
not on main but on all of the other
branches
and i want to do this for pull requests
and so here we'll do it for all branches
now with a pull request we probably oh i
also need branches
for a pull request we probably don't
want to deploy this
to kubernetes so let's delete that line
because we're not deploying it we also
don't need to set in the secrets there
because we're not doing anything with
kubernetes we don't need to log into
kubernetes there
we definitely don't want to push this
file into our registry so let's delete
that
because we're not using our registry we
can delete the docker login piece
and let's not even use our secret there
let's just call it level up devops
dash pr now this will ensure that we
build correctly it will run all of our
steps in our docker file
but it won't actually deploy anywhere
perfect now we have a new build that is
specific
to pull requests let's come back
here into source control let's take a
look at the content here
yes we're correctly ignoring our
kubernetes yaml file now very nice
let's add the readme let's add the new
build for prs
and let's say add pr build
and readme commit that
now we are pushing this to the main
branch
and so let's say git push origin main
and now because we pushed new content
into our main branch we have a new build
that kicked off
now we could come in here with clicking
on the yellow dot and that would be
great instead let's come in through
github actions
let's take a look at our build here's
our build that's running and it's
already started very nice
and now that build is going to do these
tasks
and we saw how it did the docker login
the kubernetes login
now it's downloading the uh base image
that includes our
docker our dot net build tools once it's
got that image it will copy in the rest
of the content we're storing our new get
filled
this is perfect let's see if our build
succeeds now if our build didn't succeed
the job would stop here and we wouldn't
get a new image published kubernetes
oh it looks like our build succeeded
let's run all of our tests
all of our there aren't any tests passed
let's publish this content into that new
image
it's building up that new production
image it's got
our content ready to go it's pushing it
now into our container registry
and now that we've got it pushed to our
container registry we can apply that
into kubernetes
once we've got that succeeded there's a
green build let's come back to our
homepage
and we can see now that we have a green
build
and we have that readme with the badge
showing it passing now as i began this
talk i put in the
url here to this github actions
repository and it was empty it is now
full
here's a website that we built and
published
into kubernetes using containers and
github actions
this was a lot of fun getting to show
you github actions and
containers if you have if you're
watching this later hit me up on twitter
at rob underscore rich or grab this code
right away
from robrich.org presentations and you
can fork this code and use it in your
repository as well
for those of you who are here live at
the conference
what are your thoughts and discussions
what are your questions what did i miss
rob that was fantastic uh i've not seen
a live demo like that work that smoothly
ever uh so props to you for just putting
the live demo
like down lander thanks
it is awesome i've i've sometimes been
called the evil knievel of
presentations because i'm like yeah you
shouldn't do live demos you shouldn't
type in presentations but
yeah most of mine are live demos it's
wonderful
if you can see it go live and you can
see all of the pieces
then it isn't like i'm reaching into the
magic oven
you've got all of the steps ready to be
able to replicate the results right here
so uh we have a couple questions uh let
me just
dive right in if that's okay with you
yeah definitely
let's do it this is more of your asking
about your origin story uh how did you
learn docker
and where do you recommend people to
begin their
their dockerism ooh how did i learn
docker um i want to guess that i just
started monkeying it with it
it was one of those things in my career
i
keep intentionally drawing the short
straw when we want to go learn something
else
so the first one was hey we need to
deploy our website so i was the one that
figured out how to
deploy to iis when we started moving
into linux
hey who wants to become the linux admin
sure i want to learn that
as we move to containers how do we
deploy to containers
let me dive in and go figure that out so
i just started monkeying with it and
figuring it out
how would i learn today
i would hope that you would watch videos
like this or read blog posts find
tutorials
and then start to replicate that see if
you can build it a little bit
differently
change it to match your needs and
the best part get the build to break and
then figure out why it broke and get it
to be better
you might choose to take smaller pieces
um in this case
i took one of the more challenging
things of building up a docker image and
then
running it directly in containers
running it on kubernetes you may choose
to
build an image and run it on docker
desktop and get it to work there
and then take on the kubernetes part
after that
it is a lot of fun and once you've got a
devops pipeline like this
then you can dive into all kinds of
interesting things
in this case we chose to build
containers we could build azure web apps
or azure functions or lambda functions
you could build php or java or ruby code
just as easily as
in this case we built a.net website
thank you i i know that's kind of a
broad question like how
how to get into this all together but i
can appreciate that it's basically just
raising your hand and jumping in to the
deep end of the pool
for real um oh uh so kelsey asks could
you talk more about how you set up the
secrets in github
uh specifically they looked really cool
and that they are eager to implement
that in their own code
most definitely let's flip over to the
github screen and talk about those
secrets
here i come into settings and in the
settings i scroll down here on the left
to secrets and here's my list of secrets
here's all the ones that i've created so
far
now to create a new one i'll come in
here to say new repository secret and i
can give it a name
new secret why is it all uppercase
because i did because it kind of matches
environment variables
then i'll give it a value some value
some value here now this value can be
a json object or the secret that i
copied out of s3
or you know whatever i need to do at
that point then i can choose to add that
secret
and now it's one of the secrets here in
my list
so i did that five times one for my
docker registry
username password and url once for my
kubernetes url and once for the cube
config
now in the case of the cubeconfig it's a
multi-line environment variable
and so yeah i just grabbed it in place
now the cool part is you don't see any
buttons about retrieving
there's no way to get the secret back
out of github
well kind of if you echoed it from the
command line or something
but i can choose to update it but these
secrets are baked in the github
they're not coming back out
that's good to know it's a one-way calm
um okay
we've got a couple a couple more
questions um
how did you make the jump into
orchestration and
i don't know if this is i'm going to
read both questions that might be a
two-parter
um how do you lead new teams into
uh the organization for good blue-green
deployments
good call um how do i lead organizations
into blue-green deployments
and how did i get started into devops
i actually got started when i was
building cruise control builds
you know we needed to get more
automation
in our system we needed to well stop
manually deploying it the organization
that i was in at the time
we had a production server and we kind
of had source control
but if anything went wrong we would
remote into
the production server and we would start
monkeying with it until it worked
so there was visual studio installed on
the production server and we'd fire up
visual studio and debug
the production website until we got it
to work of course
that did really bad things for users
so the first thing that i needed to do
was document the value
so i started off saying well let's
create
a source control system that is really
robust
and is that single source of truth next
let's build up a devops pipeline
that will automatically build and
validate and publish that code
at the point where we had a devops
pipeline that source control and the
build completely made sense now
let's do it on our local machine and
publish it
into that content the added benefit
there was we created a dashboard
where executives could walk into the
room and if they saw green
then they knew all was good and if they
saw red then they knew there was a
problem
and that gave a whole lot more
visibility for the dev team
to non-technical users that was perfect
along the way we documented the value at
each phase
okay now we're at the point where we
want to do more robust deployments
rather than taking the system down
and pushing up a new pushing up the
content into place
let's do blue green deployments now the
beauty of a blue green deployment is we
have two environments blue and green
and so with blue in service
let's replace the green side let's put
new content up on the green
servers once the green stuff is in place
and we've validated we've smoked
tested it then we can flip dns from blue
to green
and now green is the live side next
deployment we can do that to the blue
side
now this is perfect when we have durable
servers as we get closer into
containers we'll do a blue green type of
experience
we will spin up new containers and take
down the old containers
but we'll probably do that much more
transparently
the cloud is wonderful in being able to
facilitate this
because the cloud gives us utility
building we don't need to have two
sets of hardware available we just in
that
course of transition spin up maybe 1.2
1.5 percent of the times the hardware
as we're transitioning over to the new
containers once the content is good
then we'll shut down the old one and we
still only have one time the compute
in our cluster with a blue green
deployment
typically we're looking at on-prem like
resources and we have twice the hardware
provisioned
that's where containers can really help
us leverage our hardware in a much more
effective manner
i love it thank you you answered that
one tip tip to tale
um i did have one question uh this was
actually for me um
working i seen you do this wizardry with
github
do you have any contrast with gitlab and
doing the same level of of integrations
great question so how would i do this in
github
in get lab or in bitbucket or in
jenkins or in cruise control you'll
notice
that our build process right here in
github actions is running
a few command utilities
command line steps this is really the
only thing that is magic about this
build is those four commands
we're going to do a docker build to
docker push set in our commands and cube
ctl apply
now we could build a whole jenkins
plug-in mechanism
or a git lab build pipeline but
it's really just those four steps if i
really needed to move
to different providers i would probably
put these
four steps in a build.sh and just call
that build.sh
from wherever i needed to go so
if that build.sh was called from gitlab
versus github
that's totally fine if i call it from
jenkins that's easy enough as well
it's just those four steps that allows
me to do things
now we did need to do a kubernetes login
and a docker login and that
will be different between different
environments so
yeah we probably will need to find a
jenkins plugin
or the get lab experience to be able to
log into those resources ultimately
though
the more you can separate your build
logic from your
build vendor the easier it is to
transition if that is a concern
create a build.sh and call it from your
build script
and now all your build is is this really
dumb
experience that um watches the thing on
this side and calls the script on that
side
it's really smooth
i i can appreciate that that's really
easy separations thank you for
for walking us through that um we do
have uh
one final question i think um
so you've been a teacher uh
when it comes to enterprise software
almost nothing is taught in schools to
prepare students for enterprise work
uh if you could revamp the education
system so that someone could do what you
just did during your demo
like yeah is that even possible how can
you
give this kind of enterprise level
experience to students
that is a great question part of what
makes school
different from enterprise is they have
different motivations
in school our goal is to impress the
professor
in business that really doesn't work
impressing your boss is interesting but
the goal of business is to make money
so we have a whole lot more pragmatic
things
the analogy that i like to say is you
did so well in your homework you do his
homework too
some of the things that we miss in
school is source control
and team collaboration i would love to
get those
topics into schools in
educational programs in ways that where
they're taught programming
i've seen some programs where they have
team projects and collaborative
experiences
where you get to push and pull code and
have merge conflicts those are great
experiences to have in school so that
when you meet those problems in
enterprise
you can handle them in a really elegant
way ultimately though
you know maybe contribute to open source
maybe work on hobby projects
you'll start to get similar corporate
like experience while you're in school
and then once you get your first gig
then hopefully it won't be too much of a
transition to be able to start providing
value for your employer and your users
love it thank you that was a the
impression
professors uh landed well here you got
uh laughs from the crowd
so um well let me we'll close it out
there uh what's the best way for people
to get a hold of you uh after this rob
you can grab the code from robrich.org
presentations click in to level up your
devops and you'll get straight to the
github repository
and hit me up on twitter at rob
underscore rich and let's continue this
conversation this was so much fun
we're so glad to have you take care yeah
thanks everyone our next call is in six
our next
our last speaker is in six minutes so
hang out we'll be right back thank you